foreign
let's go to Stephanie in
Ventura Ventura Boulevard California
what's up Stephanie
hi Dr John how are you I'm good what are
you doing
good I'm currently sitting in my car
alone
is that is this a good thing or a bad
thing it's a great thing I I'll tell you
a little bit about me but I'm a moment
are you a mom of small kids you have
five under six yes
so there's a little back story to like
my question today and basically it's
five children Hey listen I don't know
what your backstory is we just take a
minute
you're all by your Hey listen here's the
deal if you just want to hang up the
phone right now and just sit there
quietly for 20 minutes that that will
probably be more beneficial than
anything I'm gonna say to you this
morning just ah right wow five kids
under six
yeah
okay good for you all right let's hear
the back story let's do this
are twins and they just turned one
because you know what why not why not
you know what hey here's what I love you
and your husband were like
yeah let's have one more and he was like
I don't know if I can do this or you
were like that one of you which one was
it oh him for sure okay he's like I
don't and he thought
for her I'll do one more tell me about
tell me about the conversation when you
were like so plot twist
how did that conversation go well the
plan was
it so that was the plan and then we had
our first two a year apart and then our
third we gave it a little bit of a
three-year buffer and so with my with
our fourth I was like let's just do it
again we've done that we can handle that
and
um then surprise
to two more beautiful babies came if you
how many diapers are in your home right
now used and unused
oh Lord knows I don't know there has to
be a thousand I have no idea
it was wild
hey God bless you yeah I don't know what
to say man God bless you
all right so how can I how can I how can
I I don't know what I can offer you and
you haven't even asked your question yet
but go for it
well I'm just finding that having so
many kids so quickly has kind of caught
up to me in brilliant every way
um but I'm just finding that a lot of my
day is full of other people's needs and
um somebody asked me the other day like
what do you like to do for fun and all I
could say was sleep it was like I'm so
sad I don't even know I know there's
nothing sad about that at all
um it's like John Mayer wrote a new song
called your body is a jungle gym right
you just got yes kids all over people
all over you hey and by the way they're
one now right your your twins are fully
one
yes okay
so his husband started like raising the
eyebrow like hey
uh I mean see you you are never your own
you're never your own listen no if the
if the most
erotic fantasy you could summon right
now combined with the most realistic
physical and mental health things you
could summon and you put them all in one
big jar and shook it up what would come
out is just sleep right yeah I mean
that's like if he came in and was like
hey you want to turn the lights down low
you'd be like yep and I'll be asleep in
eight seconds like so that that honestly
doesn't
relieve yourself I mean it's like give
yourself peace okay you are that's the
goal you're you're everywhere and you're
just it's winter and so you gotta wear a
coat right it just is it just is six
hundred six or five under six
man
um
here's here's a here's what I think well
here's what I've seen help a lot okay
there's three three kind of bullet
points I would attach to life two of
them are relatively easy they're
uncomfortable but they're easy the third
is really challenging okay the first one
is be very clear about the reality of
this season
it just is
it's not fun it's so lovable and
exciting and all of that it's the best
worst time
and I I want to free you from the
moments you're like
I hate everybody and your husband walks
in and you just look at him and say I
hate you the most and you just want to
go run screaming into the snow
uh or you're in California so you don't
have that you want to go run screaming
into the ocean right those that's okay
you're not a bad mom because you want
your kids just just to shut up you're
not a bad moms because you want your
kids can you just go away so I can you
know what I want to do here's what I
want to do I want to go to the bathroom
all by myself
I want to wipe with nobody staring at me
that's what I want I want that more than
anything right that's okay totally I
want you to know you're not a bad mom
okay you're not a bad mom okay
um be very clear about the reality of
the season and that leads to number two
you haven't done this in a while and
you're at a point now where your kids
are out of I don't see survival mode
right they still have to have to have to
have their mom right but you know the
difference between like a one-year-old
and a five day old right totally
um you got to be very very clear about
what you need in this season
and my guess is
um you have been living with a very with
a scarcity mindset there's only this
much time and there's this many kids and
so that question seems absurd it's
insane right
um you've run long enough without any
Oxygen
and if you don't make a shift at some
point to put your health and wellness at
the center of this thing this ship just
runs out of gas
or it runs a ground right I'm mixing my
metaphors the truck runs out of gas so
asking yourself being very specific okay
for the next four weeks what do I need
and that is going to dictate your budget
that's going to dictate we all spend
money on it's going to dictate what you
end up asking your husband to do or what
support you need we need to hire a
housekeeper I'm going to ask Mom to come
visit for a few months like what do you
need and let's do this on a 30-day
increment
and let's get in the habit of asking her
okay what do I need right now and you
have to hear me say the greatest gift
you can give your kids
is to speak your needs out loud and give
other people opportunity to help you
meet those needs
okay even if that's hiring a high school
kid to come over and just be in the
house while you take a two-hour nap
can you imagine how awesome a two-hour
nap would be we do have a nanny there
you go so let's be super clear about
what we need sometimes it's just when
you hire nanny in the in your situation
it's just like I just whatever I need
help with it let's be real real clear
okay and this leads to number three
this is the I think the big the big
thing happens to all of us happened to
me with one kid happened to me with two
kids and you have a thousand kids and
it's happening to me too
I just kept imagining my life as it was
before I had kid number one
and I tried to just insert the new kids
into that world
in that world before I had kids my wife
and I could just have sex whenever we
wanted to we could spend money on pretty
much whatever we wanted to we could just
travel whatever we could just do
whatever we wanted
because we were in a glitch in The
Matrix we had grown-up jobs and we had
no kids and so I didn't know at the time
but we had very limited responsibility
and I kept trying to
just insert kids into that world and I
never stopped to realize that everything
about my world had changed
and so there's something about exhaling
and getting out of the house for a day
or half a day and you sound like that's
insane and cool man we can do extra
pumping and storing for a while you and
your husband go away for half a day and
you have to reimagine your life because
it's new now
and if he's still waiting for hit that
crazy fun girlfriend wife that he had
before and if you're still wanting to
get back to whatever that phrase if we
can just get back to if I can just get
to that is a recipe for disaster in your
relationship
yeah I actually I actually think we're
doing honestly almost the opposite like
oh we could just get to the three-year
Mark three years been like our magic
number for our kids like okay we could
just get to three years like we'll be
able to leave the house again or like
not be run by Naps there is that I mean
there's definitely markers right you're
running a marathon you're like dude if I
can just get to mile five up that big
hill then miles five through seven are
downhill there's there's definitely a
component to that what you leave out of
that equation is oh then we can finally
get to that if we can just get everybody
to three and you don't understand what
life is gonna be like when you have a
nine-year-old
right and that's a whole other set of
challenges right and then when when your
nine-year-old turns 12 and is like he
dumped me and now we got a whole other
set right so you're always going to be
shuffling and moving and then what
happens is if you keep waiting for the
next milestone
like I worked in colleges for 20 years
the number of parents who come and
they're just they're they are wide-eyed
what just happened my kids are gone I
just dropped off my last kid and we kept
waiting for well then they get to high
school and then we'll be able to and
then when they get to then now they're
just gone
and so I would encourage you to
reimagine your life full of
one-year-olds everywhere
and our life right now is not a life
conducive to going out unless we have
seven to eight babysitters here to help
out right
um and that means that means the nights
we go out they're going to be very very
special
and that means we're going to be
intentional on the bottom and that means
we're going to be gross about them we're
going to text each other a week out and
be like ew ha date coming up because
that's how intentional we have to be
because this is our new world in the
world we could just be like dude we got
a Bonus let's just go get steak that
world's over right now it's over and we
can be sad about it but it didn't exist
here's our new world here's what dates
are going to look like we have to still
go on them here's what romance is going
to look like romance might be just
holding hands and watching the office
till you doze off
romance oh honey you want to get me hot
and bothered go change diapers in the
middle of the night just once a week
just right I just that I won't be able
to breathe I'll be so hot and bothered
but I'll be asleep and you won't know it
so like it's reimagining your life as it
is not just white knuckling it until you
get to some magic Milestone because the
milestones
man they they
you get one Milestone here but you're
off to the races on another one and you
just never think you can stop I will say
this when all of your kids are able to
go to the bathroom on their own and get
in and out of the shower on their own
that is pretty awesome not gonna lie
it's pretty amazing
looking forward to it like right now I
have a like I'm six-year-old and 12 year
old I can just say y'all go shower and
they do and I can just stare off into
space it's pretty awesome I'm not gonna
lie and I haven't wiped another human's
butt in a while so it's that's pretty
awesome I'm not gonna lie that is a
milestone but don't miss the
one-year-old years waiting until they
become three-year-old years because
you're gonna wait until they become 10
year old years and then they're gonna
leave right be in it with them and most
importantly being with your husband okay
yeah but
do you just ever sit and weep just cry
oh all the time okay
have you uh do you have a group of women
that you can text and talk and say am I
going crazy
FPU yeah
that sounded like shenanigans
one okay
and can you tell that person everything
yeah okay
do you can you get one more
I can sure try
I think you can and here's the deal or
maybe two more and let them know I'm
starting a text thread because I'm going
insane
because I have five kids under six and
so I'm gonna text y'all when I have a
question about something or when I
um feel like shaving my head just to see
what I look like without any hair like
whatever is hap like
they people will be honored to be on the
other end of that text message okay and
it would be really gangster if you got
together once a week just to have nachos
and be like whoa
okay
you're not abandoning your kids if you
do something with other people once like
you know on some interval once a week or
something like that in fact it'd be a
gift to them and it'd be a gift to you
yeah
cool
awesome thank you so much
I I keep I'm like I want to say I'm
sorry but I'm not sorry I'm super
excited for you but I just know I am so
grateful thank you I really um respect
your show and what you do well well I
appreciate you I've I I can tell you I
really respect you my gosh y'all are in
it in it to win it
um yeah reimagine your life
everything's different now reimagine it
and that should be a fun and exciting
exercise it'll be filled with grief be
filled with some I'm bummed out
but man that's pretty awesome when you
go all right here's what it is we have
lots of diapers in the house let's make
this work not only let's just make this
work let's make this incredible